Our square root method also works for equations in this form. Notice that we
just have a quantity over here, squared equal to some number. This means we can
take the square root of the left side and the right side. When we take the
square root of this side, it undoes the square power, so we're just left with
this quantity, ax plus b. So, I have ax plus b on the left side of our equation
and plus or minus root c on the right side of our equation. Next we subtract b
from both sides, so that way we can start to isolate the X. Notice that this
negative b, is not like terms with radical c. All I can do, is list this as
negative b plus or minus the square root of c. Finally, to get x by itself, we
divide both sides by the coefficient of a. So we know x could equal negative b
plus root c divided by a. Or x could equal negative b minus root c, all divided
by a. There's really two solutions here.